loved his work on Desperate Housewives
in on Mad Men and you can catch him the
season 3 premiere of lethal weapon on
Fox tonight at 9:00 Eastern Time keep
that going might keep that going because
we dialed 8 6 75 309 and asked for Kevin
Ron rope here and look who is here
I made it on the show is this your
choice of once my choice Tommy - Tommy
Tommy - go - and karaoke as well is that
your karaoke can you it's one of them
yeah can you reach this oh you know oh
yeah she's alright now you can the place
out
Tommy - to everybody you can really hit
that come up cocktails in I can do a
couple of contraception how do you do
that at the big slick this year did you
die - Jin y'know Taryn Taryn killin yeah
it was too much it was he was so good
there I feel like I could open for him
right he's really good he's so good he's
really he's I'm thinking hit he can get
up there really high I used to be able
to but I can't quite get all of them so
that would be your truck I gotta be
going down to George's in there Oh
Charlie Daniels didn't you have he had
more than oh I'm talking about for
karaoke Oh Cara not one-hit wonder oh no
Charlie Daniels is an icon okay now we
understand here I went to karaoke yeah
one-hit wonder right there I got to be
honest with you here and I'm gonna be
completely honest and I know that this
might be some slings and arrows coming
my way
oh if put to the test and I'm doing that
now
I would have bet I would have thought
Rick Springfield sang that song that's
why there one had wonder 8 6 7-5 3 or
not yeah is that wrong he'd know Rick
Springfield was Jenny's Jenny's girl
this is Jenny's girl do you think
anybody really has that phone number and
people dial it had that number all over
America had to change the number so we
called the Los Angeles the 3:103 oh no
five three Oh known 3106 seven five
three oh nine eight six seven five
Kevin Ramla doesn't show exciting
exciting radio should we do a jerky boy
sketch
hey I'm gonna bring my shoes and my
glasses hello it's Jenny it's three
rings yeah they're not answering
okay we tried there you go the I want to
get that number and just have the song
playing on a loop oh man let me describe
for the radio listener oh yeah
right now well--there's yeah go ahead
well describe your shoes well first of
all these are LSU shoes they say LSU
right here but more importantly inside
oh my god says Tigers here and this one
was go okay so what you put you put on
that you and then yeah and then every
single time then you hear this noise
when you put the shoe on and then you've
got I didn't know that you could have a
long-sleeve Ralph Lauren Polo zip up LSU
sure yeah oh yeah it's like a pullin
Louisiana we're only found in Louisiana
I believe were you concerned about some
Louisiana Tech situation at some point
over the weekend no and let me tell you
why okay coach o is so genius he's not
using all of his good plays he's saving
them for Georgia and Alabama so we put a
couple of backups in there we don't show
them the good stuff they ran the ball
mm-hmm they ran the ball they're saving
the big plays for the big game okay no
reason you know the whole running up the
score think it's ridiculous so we scored
60 against Kalamazoo it doesn't matter
that doesn't mean anything anymore yeah
30 wins and the losses 38:21 was the
final skins and losses so what do you
think you think you got a chance for
real your heart of hearts
heart of hearts you know what Alabama's
looked like you see what Georgia looks
like heart of hearts
kevin rom you got a shot yes and I'll
tell you why because they're gonna be
defensive games our defense is that good
you think it's gonna be a defensive game
with tool out there yes - uh - he has
not played against a second a secondary
like LSU yet - uh may win the Heisman
Trophy may be the first Heisman
trophy-winning quarterback yes to play
fewer snaps than the backup yes
that's entirely a monster and they
terrify me but if anyone has a shot it's
us how bad
do you want to beat Nick Saban I cannot
express in words how much I want him to
lose to LSU mainly because he was our
coach and Saban was at LSU yes we win a
national championship
he gets his big chance to go to the NFL
which in apologized he says I got to go
to the NFL but guys don't worry I'm
gonna be in the NFL I'm not coming back
a year and a half later not only does he
come back he comes to the SEC West
that's just wrong it's just wrong and by
the way if he was our coach I would love
him if he was if he was on my team it
you know it's it's what's it's like lamb
beer if lamb beers on your team he's the
best player ever and if he's not you
hate him he's exactly that's that's the
ultimate he is out oh my god playing
against you oh my gosh draymond Green is
the current version of that right now on
the NBN yes like you you hate him if
you're going against the Warriors and if
you're member Lee do you remember the
Warriors go dream are they gonna be the
San Francisco warriors next year no no
they're still gonna well they're still
the state is still golden regardless of
which side of the bay in which they're
they play Kevin ROM here on the Rich
Eisen show and then you know we had
Brees on in our number two and what you
know what he what he continues to do
he's now a 39 years old see which wish
in in football years it's like 72 it is
that it is it's really been moved one
one word spin move I know and just to
see that and then I knew it too
he everybody talks about Brady's ability
to sneak the ball and it's very good
Brees is the king of the sticking the
ball out jumping over the center and
that's the way they won the game is
that's how you lose an arm it's those
guys are 350 pounds right coming
right he's so a thank you guys what do
you think you're the Saints change never
count him out although last year oh it
still hurts how still hurts would you
watch this game okay so I was watching
the game or the oh that that's the
spinner on watch this Oh Juke I didn't
have to add that to Madden football
there you go take this in
last year I was
watching the Minnesota game which is
also it's painful to wear purple for
that reason hmm
I was watching it at home but I had it
was a Sunday night game I had to fly
back here I live in Sacramento I fly
back here for work on lethal the next
morning and so I'm watching the game I
call my uber to go to the airport I'm
standing outside looking through the
window as they score right so I'm in my
in the car watching on my phone as we
score within no time left and I'm like
that's it we won mmm I get into the
Sacramento Airport and these two guys
are watching on their phones and they
start screaming we D we won we won and I
went yeah wait who's we
oh no and I had to run upstairs to the
bar to see the replay and still can't
believe what oh that's they don't yeah I
can't believe we're showing that as your
own right now that's just me that's just
how do you it is truly one of the most
cutting losses getting destroyed yeah
they just get I feel like we would have
we would have put up a fight I feel like
we had a chat a like last year was a big
big chance for us last year I think it
would have been it definitely I agree
with you I think it would've been a much
more competitive and no one wants me
just to win Philadelphia Falls I mean
yeah you know I pick up what you're
saying so you live in Sacramento yes
work down here in Los Angeles on New
York so does it do you go to Kings games
do you go to I have been Jay King I've
been - oh you're Kings fan yes okay why
do you live in Sacramento my wife is a
pediatric heart surgeon and got a job at
UC Davis so we made lives here is what
you're saying yeah yeah UC Davis
homeless ken O'Brien yes
New York jet quarterbacks Davis Hornets
yeah that Sac State the UC Davis uh I
don't know he got me on that sac States
the Hornets UC Davis UC Davis was
looking also home of Chris Peterson the
current coach of Washington football he
was a quarterback there as well I'm out
of UC Davis so let's move that's it do
you have eight children as well because
we have the one child okay that's just
weird because that's it Sacramento I
think of the Kings and I think of the
Bradford family and then no Avedis
enough and now that now the roms
Bradford yes and I don't mean Sam no no
I'm telling would you am I is he related
is Sam related
to the broker I don't think so I mean
because if kids there's a lot you know
the trees spread out the branches are
deep if he was then three was enough as
in games for Sandford see now I see
Davis Aggies uh Aggie of course of
course really appreciate that thank you
so your work in lethal weapon in this I
guess spoiler alert
Riggs is no longer wait what is that is
that did I spoil it for you really is
this true is that true yes oh gosh did I
tell any tales out of school and of
course not no no so well I mean I feel
like I feel like when there's a gunshot
to the chest on a grave I don't know man
have you seen Game of Thrones
I mean Jon Snow you know what I mean
like the world television the dead
spoiler alert oh you know what I mean is
that true I don't know so you are part
of a lethal weapon where we're I guess
advancing the story yes yes so we have
it this year we have a new character
coming in Cole Colt Cole yeah Cole sorry
Sean he's got court Colt McCoy right yes
Sean William Scott comes in who plays a
very different character who is amazing
he and what was really cool about what
he did is for the for two months he did
this like crazy fight training because
one of the his characters idiosyncrasies
is that he doesn't want to use the
weapon because he's used weapons so much
in the past he would rather not pull a
weapon so he likes hand-to-hand fighting
so you got to think like Bourne Identity
bike style fighting really close handing
and stuff which is cool right and and
Damon Wayans and you Jordana Brewster
good cast man
and you're on every single day you're on
audience madman's on at 7:00 Eastern
Time every single day yeah what was that
like being on that show at the height of
it that was magical that was that was
something special that's like I don't
know what to Ridley it reel in here like
being on SportsCenter early on you know
in the early days it's like there's
something special about that that group
of people and and Matt Winer is writing
and the whole writing crew and just the
the amount of detail they went into
there was a scene when my secretary
hands me a plane ticket and in the scene
I literally take it and put in my pocket
and I still have this plane ticket if
you open it up it is it has the Carbon
Copy
and I guarantee if you look up the dates
of the flights of the date and time of
those flights that is the flight number
like the detail if they handed you a
file on her she it was a file on her she
it was all yes there wasn't just like no
papers no it wasn't like medical records
from the 60s which is usually what you
get so was it really like Scotch in the
glass to fish it bends on how late in
the day the series we did have a full
bar in the makeup trailer really oh yeah
come on oh yeah
no one we people stayed after work I
mean that's the only show I've ever been
on where people came on their days off
to hang out yeah so burn them like you
and Slattery and everybody we just
you're just while you're getting a
little bit of the powder makeup after
after work yeah after work now after I
never during work never during work
no that was that's like water and I
don't T years no no no I'm just totally
it's jokey but after work we would mad
we would play we were always playing
games we were playing cribbage and
dominoes and cards and we had a like a
table with a little outdoor area like a
patio so who's the best poker player on
the set we didn't play poker so we asked
our player on the Sun oh we had we had
left one week long cribbage tournament
okay that and we'd play teams John was
really good Hamm was really good
that's just sure that's a shocker that
hams really what a shocker
this just in yeah this just in handsome
guy is also talented at cards good at
cribbage what's something good to see
you Kevin you too good to see you man
because Kevin ROM on Twitter I follow
yeah you went over there to get what's
your home at Kevin Rome okay
instruments your handicap oohs you know
seven ten all right I'm gonna eat
something index okay oh the one other
thing October 16th or 18th whatever that
Thursday night is my wife and I are the
co-hosts of the March of Dimes signature
chef event in Sacramento California
fantastic you're in Sacramento come and
if not you can go on my Twitter and
there's a link to donate fantastic
Orchard I'm great cause March of Dimes
season premiere of Lethal Weapon season
three tonight at 9:00 Eastern Time
time sir my pleasure to see a Kevin ROM
here on the Roboto 8 dial 8 6 75 309 see
if anybody answer you know it do the 3 1
a do the Louisiana area code 3
1-800 I that you're gonna get you're
gonna hear coach Joe answer and you tell
Sarah it's never bet against the Saints
again Oh Sarah Tiana bet against South
oh that's right Falcon so you have to
put your mouth on it you have to put
your money no no she dressed up and they
made fun of it - here's the thing is it
usually the road team wins that game
yeah you know yeah yeah I wouldn't be
surprised if Atlanta goes into the
Superdome and wins the the rematch yeah
that's the way it goes
good to see you Kevin my pleasure it's
okay your phone calls at 8:40 for 204
rich we will pick that number up the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience